ERIC SCHMIDT: It's a
great pleasure for me
to welcome back my two very
good friends Bill and Kevin,
who have a book they
want to talk about.
I wanted to start
by saying that I've
known the governor for
more than a decade.
His background, of course,
was a political leader,
secretary of energy,
governor, and a negotiator
of interesting things.
When we initially thought
about going to North Korea, who
better to go with than
Governor Richardson.
And the best part of the
story, from my perspective,
is we were sitting
in Beijing, and we
can't take our mobile phones in.
And so we have to give our
mobile devices, all of them
to the Google Earth
Chinese people.
So my daughter and I, Bill
and Kevin, and a few others,
we give them all to
Chinese Google Earth
and then my daughter says, are
your fingers twitching yet,
Dad?
And for a few hours, it
was just really weird,
and then we discovered that
we actually liked each other.
KEVIN BLEYER: Right.
We had conversations.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And we actually
spent four days together
getting to know each
other by ourselves,
and we had the most
wonderful time.
Governor, it's a pleasure
to have you here with Kevin
to promote your book,
so welcome to Google.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON:
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Now, I
think with this audience,
maybe what we should do is
I'll ask a few questions
and we have some Dory questions
and maybe some questions
here from the audience.
I think there's actually a
pretty interesting question
sort of right now, which has to
do with the bizarre activities
of the last two weeks
of the US government.
Is that a fair characterization?
it's just bizarre.
Just bizarre.
And I think we don't
get it, and perhaps we
don't get it because
we're too rational,
and this requires sort of
an irrational planning,
thinking, negotiating mind.
You've faced these before.
Go ahead.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Well
first, thank you, Eric.
Thank you, Google.
Congratulations, 10%
increase in your stock today.
And if you get a chance
to read the book,
I'm giving enormous credit
to this guy, Kevin Bleyer
and "The Daily Show" guy.
What we tried to do--
ERIC SCHMIDT: We should
say that Kevin is actually
a professional comedy writer who
moonlights with the two of us
to help us to diplomat.
And Kevin, you've worked for?
KEVIN BLEYER: You name it.
Six years for Bill Maher,
three years for Dennis Miller,
and then for the
last eight years
I was a writer on
"The Daily Show."
ERIC SCHMIDT: You liberal.
KEVIN BLEYER: I am
a comedic mercenary
or a rabid schizophrenic.
I'm not quite sure,
back and forth.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: But
what we try to do
in this book and President
Clinton used to say,
bad people like Richardson.
Send him to talk to them.
ERIC SCHMIDT: By the way, you
don't treat President Clinton
very well in this book.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Well,
but I'll get to that.
The point that I'm
trying to make here
is that we're trying to
make this book not just, OK,
I negotiated with these
bad guys, Saddam Hussein,
North Korea, Cuba, Sudan.
But how do you apply
this to your daily life?
When you're negotiating
with your spouse, your wife,
your kid, you know, what--
ERIC SCHMIDT: Kevin, do
you have an analogy there
or what's your comedic
objective there?
KEVIN BLEYER: After
all, it's best
to treat your spouse like
an armchair dictator.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON:
It's to find ways
to get things done
with difficult people,
but on the shut down,
on the shut down,
I wrote a little piece in the
"Washington Post" last week.
Obviously, nobody's
listening to me,
but I suggested four things
that they should do differently.
And this is our Congress.
These are our leaders.
I was a congressman
15 years, so I
know the intense
pressure, the media glare.
You've got to suck up to your
caucuses when you're a leader.
You know, I'm tough.
We're going to be
tough on our side.
I would have done four
things differently.
One, they needed mediation.
That's reached a point
where it was so personal.
They hate each other so much.
They're talking to the cameras
instead of to each other.
They're talking
to their caucuses
to show how they're
strong leaders,
and they want to get
reelected speakers, et cetera.
So I would have had somebody
like Henry Paulson, Tim
Geithner, ex Secretaries of the
Treasury that are respected,
that know budgets that maybe
can go in and cool things down.
Number two, I would have had the
president or somebody take them
away from the hill,
go to the White House,
lock up the locale,
and say, you're
not coming out until
you come up with a deal.
Because what happens when
you're in intense pressure,
you're showing off to the press,
to your own constituencies.
Set a date certain for the
end of the negotiation.
I would have had everybody
at the White House.
Let him stay at
the Lincoln bedroom
and see if they-- that's
supposed to be funny.
KEVIN BLEYER: Pack 'em all in.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON:
And then thirdly, I
think there was always,
Eric, outlines of a deal.
But what happened was, the
very intense Tea Party people,
what I would have done if I
had been Boehner, the Speaker,
I would have tested the
Tea Party guys on a vote.
You know, machos,
40 votes, we want
to shut down the government.
I bet you there would have
been some peeling off.
Until you put
somebody to a vote,
go on record, because you'll
be attacked, pro and con, when
you take a vote.
So I would have done
that differently.
The last thing that I would
do, the outlines of the deal
were obvious.
OK.
President's going to not do
anything about Obamacare.
That's passed as
law of the land.
The default, the debt limit,
take that off the table.
That should have been done
early, a shut down negotiation.
But say, OK.
What we're going
to do now is, we're
going to talk about
what the country needs.
The country needs
economic growth.
immigration reform.
The country needs
entitlement reform.
The country needs tax
reform, regulatory reform,
technology initiatives.
So I would have framed the
negotiation differently,
but now, I think it's crucial
that the president step
in and say, OK.
This is a bad episode,
but we're going
to move on and
pursue an agenda, not
just it's related to
the budget shutdown.
That's what I would have done.
ERIC SCHMIDT: It's
interesting that in your book,
you have a lot of
sort of subtle points
about negotiating,
which I actually
learned a number
by just reading it.
And you tell an
interesting story
about you had been
aligned with Mrs. Clinton
and then you switched
allegiance to Mr. Obama.
And you tell a story about
both the wrath of the Clintons,
I'll use your word, but
you also tell something
about a mistake
you made in that.
Can you take us through that?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Yeah.
ERIC SCHMIDT: It's rare
for a political leader
to admit a mistake, and I think
this one is an interesting one
because you may have
been right, but you
may have handled it a
little bit differently.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Yeah.
Well, in the book, I
point out the successes
we had, the good techniques,
but also the mistakes, this one
and one I made in Cuba when
I got really ticked off
at the Cubans and denounced
them for not turning
over a prisoner, which
was a terrible mistake.
With the Clintons,
this is the scene.
I'd been a
presidential candidate,
which I didn't
last too long, OK?
But no jokes.
I lasted three primaries,
but still the only
Hispanic in the race,
Richardson, excellent Hispanic
name.
Nobody knew period about me.
And so people wanted
my endorsement.
Obama would call.
Hillary would call.
John Edwards would call.
Biden was already out.
I always tell Biden, I got
more votes than you do,
Iowa, New Hampshire.
He doesn't like that but--
So what happened was,
I was being solicited,
and Bill Clinton, I'd
been very close to him.
I had been his UN Ambassador,
Secretary of Energy
We'd been pals together.
I defended him on
the Lewinsky stuff.
We'd watch TV together.
And he says, I want
to talk to you.
I want you to endorse Hillary.
I want to come to Santa Fe
to the governor's mansion.
But let's just chill out.
We'll watch the Superbowl.
And I said, OK.
But instead of saying, no,
which I should have because it
raised enormous
expectations, his visit.
You know, the great negotiator
himself, former president,
my friend coming to Santa Fe
to ask for my endorsement.
And there was such a media glare
and then when I didn't endorse,
it was a mistake.
I shouldn't have-- well, when
I didn't endorse Hillary,
it was a mistake
to have him come
to Santa Fe with that glare.
And I say that in the book.
I raised expectations.
I made him look bad.
ERIC SCHMIDT: But what's
interesting in your framing
of this is that, the
individuals you're working with
are surrounded by other actors
that put pressure on them.
In your case, a lot
of it is the media,
and once somebody gets
committed in the media,
it gets much, much
harder for them
to do anything
rational with you.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON:
And at the time,
I really was soul searching.
I saw Obama, I thought he was
something special, something
new, inspirational.
I loved his speeches, the
people he was attracting.
I knew the Clintons, and I
served well with the Clintons.
But I did say, oh, jeez.
All the same Clinton
people are coming back.
Let's try something
new with Obama.
That's supposed
to be funny, but--
KEVIN BLEYER: It was.
Trust me.
But if I may, I'm
speaking of the media,
there was a particular moment, a
media moment during the debates
that Obama gave
you the impression,
or gave you the sense
that you could trust him.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: You know, these
debates, you all watch them.
But when you're a candidate
that's not up in the polls,
they ask you very few questions.
So the media is having a field
day with Obama and Clinton.
I always used to sit next
to Obama in the debates.
They always put the
minorities on the side.
And there was a time in
one of the debates where
I'm like chatting with Obama.
We're saying just little
gossip, and no one's
asking me questions.
But all of a sudden, I think
it was Wolf Blitzer, says,
Governor Richardson, what's
your position on this issue?
And there's a slight problem
because I wasn't listening.
I was talking to Obama.
So here's my big chance, and
I'm going to blow it, right?
So Obama leans over and he says,
they asked you about Katrina.
Katrina.
My position on Katrina is--
He could have thrown me
under the bus, but
little incidents like
that, I liked the guy, you know?
Very gentle.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And
he told the truth.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Yeah.
KEVIN BLEYER: Yeah.
Right.
Exactly.
That rare moment.
That's a flub in politics.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: And so
little things like that.
And so I endorsed him, and--
KEVIN BLEYER: Not
right then, but later.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON:
I almost did then.
KEVIN BLEYER: When
you're in a debate,
probably the best tactic is
not to say, he's got my vote.
We're still in the debates.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Let's talk
a little bit about some
of the crazy people
you've dealt with
and then we'll return
to North Korea,
a large set of crazy
people, I think.
Let's talk a little
bit about Cuba.
Did you have a
special role in Cuba
because of your
Hispanic connections?
Why did you end up in Cuba
doing all of these things?
What did you, in fact, do, and
what were the Castro people
actually like?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Well, President
Clinton at the time-- I
was a congressman
at the time, but I'd
done a lot of these
unofficial missions that
had gotten results,
mainly ceasefire, getting
political prisoners out.
And I knew Castro.
I'd made visits--
this is Fidel--
and I had succeeded in getting
political prisoners, three
political prisoners out, an
immigration agreement allowing
more Cubans to come into the
United States paying less.
At one point, I remember
Jesse Jackson also
did a lot of this, Jimmy
Carter going in and trying
to bring people back.
And I remember succeeding
once with Fidel Castro.
We spoke Spanish to each other.
We talked baseball.
That was a big plus.
I mean, he's a very
interesting, fascinating guy.
He doesn't sleep at night.
He sleeps during the day.
He's up all night.
He's a night owl.
But he reads everything.
He's probably the most
intelligent leader
I met in terms of
mentally, not necessarily
his values and his policies.
But I remember pleading.
Give me some of these
Cuban political prisoners.
You're not getting any help in
the press by keeping them here.
And I remember him saying, no.
I'm not going to--
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
You know, Cubans, Latins call
each other by their last name.
They don't say Mr.
Governor or anything.
No, Richardson.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
And I said, please, please.
You gave Jesse Jackson,
the black guy, 25.
I'm asking as your Hispanic
brother, give me four.
KEVIN BLEYER: The
word is quatro.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: And you
know, he looked at me,
and he started
laughing, laughing.
He said, all right.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
So that was a real, but
then after he left power,
this is the one area where I
made a terrible mistake, Eric.
This was about two years
ago, three years ago.
I was no longer governor.
I forgot that.
When you have power, you
have a little more juice
when you're negotiating.
But I just had my foundation.
I went to Cuba.
There's this guy
named Alan Gross.
He's a contractor, an American
who got stuck in Cuba four
years ago because he was selling
telephone-- he had telephone--
KEVIN BLEYER: --wiring up some
communities to the internet,
actually.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: And they
accused him of being a spy.
He was in jail, and
it was a single issue
the divided the US and
Cuba more than anything.
By the way, I think
our policy towards Cuba
doesn't make sense, the embargo.
It makes no sense.
I mean, let American
technology come in,
democracy will come right after.
But what happened
there was I thought
I had some agreement with the
Cubans to get Alan Gross out.
We'd take them off
the terrorism list.
We would find ways to have
better ties environmentally,
drugs.
And so I had this very
contentious meeting
with the Foreign
Minister of Cuba.
I thought we were going to make
a deal, but he basically said,
Bill, you're not going
to get Alan Gross.
I'm not only not going
to let you take him away,
I'm not going to
let you see him.
And third, I want you to
leave Cuba right away.
And I said, jeez, this is a
very hospitable meeting, Bruno.
Not very funny.
And so instead of like
shutting up and leaving,
going to my hotel,
cooling down, there
were all these cameras there.
And I was angry, and
I went and I said,
Alan Gross is a hostage.
He should be allowed to leave.
The Cuban government
is being unreasonable,
and furthermore, unless I go
visit him in his hospital,
I'm not going to leave Cuba.
Four days later
I left because it
was obvious I wasn't
going to see him.
Big mistake.
When you're negotiating,
don't lose your cool.
I mean, it seems common.
Don't lose your cool.
Don't go to the press.
Don't get ticked off needlessly.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So my
rule for negotiation,
which is going to be
expanded, based on your book,
It's called PIA, which
stands, by the way,
for pain in the ass.
So patients, information,
have some alternatives.
Now, you in your book actually
lay out a deeper foundation,
and let me just summarize it.
You need to set the mood
because it has to be controlled.
Minutes matter.
You need to say yes, right?
to keep it moving along.
Humor.
I guess we should always
travel with Kevin.
KEVIN BLEYER: You're supposed
to lower the expectations.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Don't ask
for a yes, assume a yes.
Sometimes the soft sell works.
I think these examples
that you're describing
don't-- and sales
people know this--
if the customer is thinking,
keep your own mouth shut,
because when the
customer is talking,
you're winning even if it
doesn't appear to be true.
So can you kind of
codify that for us?
I mean, we have lots
of what-- Google
is involved in lots and
lots of negotiations
in lots of different
kinds of ways.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Well,
those are principles.
I think others that
I would add is,
let the other side save face.
Don't try to take
all the credit.
In other words, share the credit
in a successful negotiation.
Let the other side talk, but
also what's very important
is, try to establish
a personal connection.
In diplomacy, where the United
States, a powerful country
militarily, I
always see the turf.
This is why I end up in
North Korea or Cuba or Sudan.
I go there, and I don't
think it's a big concession.
So if it's a territorial
issue with your negotiator,
they want you to come visit them
at their headquarters, do it.
It's an easy concession.
Humor, I think,
is very important.
The good news about negotiating
with a dictator, a bad person,
is dictators can make the
decision that give you
what you want without having to
go through Congress or t press,
so you need one shot.
And what I've tried to do
is establish these rapports,
like with Saddam
Hussein when I was
trying to get two Americans out.
And we started the negotiation,
he tried to intimidate me.
ERIC SCHMIDT: By the way,
describe what he was like?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: I mean, he's
a big guy, immaculate uniform.
He had about three
knives and pistols,
and he had the revolutionary
guard around us,
so I was slightly intimidated.
And he had these beady
eyes, and he'd look at me.
And then he'd vent and say,
you know, US policy is wrong,
and your a bad country.
And what am I getting out
of these negotiations?
I give you these two Americans.
He was like really ticked off.
Then I made a terrible
mistake, another one.
I showed them the
sole of my shoe, which
to an Arab-- like
this, Eric-- is
a supreme insult, like if
you're facing each other.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Thank you
for letting me know.
KEVIN BLEYER: You've
just been insulted.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: He
left the meeting.
He stormed out.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Really?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Yeah.
And I hand this translator.
I said, is he coming back?
What's going on?
Am I toast?
He said, no.
You made a mistake.
You insulted the president.
He's coming back, and
you must apologize.
He came back.
I didn't apologize.
I said, you know, I think you
may be trying to intimidate me.
I think this is a mind game.
I'll be respectful,
but I won't apologize.
So I went back and forth.
We went back and
forth with each other.
I'm making the case
for the Americans,
and then all of a
sudden, ramrod straight,
he says, by virtue
of the section
131 of the Iraqi
Constitution, I am
going to turn over the
two Americans to you.
And my first instinct
was, hey, thanks.
Swooping in were the
Iraqi Revolutionary Guard
thinking I was going to
do something onerous--
KEVIN BLEYER: You grabbed him,
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: --or kill him.
We finished the negotiation.
We got up.
He said, I'm going
to call in the press.
And you know, Congressman,
this is through a translator,
my appearing with you
in the Iraqi press
does not help my
political standing.
And I said, well, Mr.
President, my standing with you
doesn't help mine either.
We finished.
We were heading out
and said, by the way,
he says, I noticed
that you asked--
you're a Roman
Catholic-- you asked
that you go to a
Catholic service.
And Tariq Aziz, my
Foreign Minister's wife
is a Chaldean Catholic,
so you should go.
Another lesson you learn
in dealing in a negotiation
with dictators, when you've
got what you want, and he had
already announced that I was
getting the two Americans,
get out.
Because they change their
mind, they're temperamental,
they're crazy.
You don't want them
to add something new,
some press statement
screws everything up.
So I wanted to leave right after
I had the two Americans who
I was going to pick up
at the Swiss Embassy.
And he said, no, no, no.
You said you wanted
to go to church.
I have arranged for
you to go to church.
He says, but if you
really are in a hurry,
because I'd made some excuse.
I was a congressman.
I got votes coming up,
which was not true.
It was a recess.
KEVIN BLEYER: He
would have known
that if he had Googled it.
So he didn't at the time.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Right.
So he said--
KEVIN BLEYER: I get
that all the time.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: So he says,
the only advice I have is,
when you go to the service,
don't go to confession
because if you go to confession,
you're going to be late.
KEVIN BLEYER: You'll
be there for a while.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: In
other words, jeez.
They don't have a sense
of humor, these guys.
But he was basically saying,
whatever the message,
we established like
a little connection.
He smiled.
This is the most evil
man in the world,
but I left, and I
got what I wanted.
I mean, the relationship
as you know was turbulent.
Later I was UN ambassador
probably involved
in the military
operation with him.
So--
ERIC SCHMIDT: Right.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON:
That's what happens.
Use humor.
Use a personal connection.
ERIC SCHMIDT: But
what's interesting
is, that there's
another group of people
who take the entire
opposite view of everything
that you tried to do.
Stonewall, firewall,
don't engage,
they're criminals, they're
assholes, shoot them,
and so forth, and so on.
You've heard all of this.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Yeah.
KEVIN BLEYER: And when
the State Department
tells you to recite
that in front of them,
you usually decline.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Yeah.
I mean, the State
Department would give me
talking points when I'm
talking to a bad guy
because they want
US policy reflected.
KEVIN BLEYER: So Dear Mr.
Bad Guys, you are a bad guy.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON:
You are a bad guy.
KEVIN BLEYER: How
are we doing so far?
Yeah.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: And I'm
trying to get something
from the bad guy.
That's not a good start,
so I don't use that.
KEVIN BLEYER: So
the exact 180 degree
from that is how you approached
Omar Suleiman, in Egypt.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Yeah.
I mean, there humor, and
sometimes macabre humor.
And this one worked
because we were
trying to get this
Israeli named Shalit.
You all remember we
were involved in that.
I was governor, but
I had some people
try to get this Israeli
military guy out.
And Omar Suleiman was the head
of security in Egypt, the most
notorious human rights
violator, put people in prison.
And I knew that.
And I opened up the meeting.
I only talked to
him on the phone,
and I'll tell you a
quick lesson on that.
But I started the conversation
by saying, Vice President
Suleiman, it's good to be here.
Now, where are we?
He says, well, this is my
headquarters, et cetera.
I said, well, now
where are the dungeons?
Where do you take the
people's fingernails off?
Is it nearby here?
ERIC SCHMIDT: You said this?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: I said that.
Yeah.
And he looked at me.
Huh huh huh huh.
You know, and all his-- so it
broke the ice a little bit.
It did.
KEVIN BLEYER: It's
fair to say that could
have gone either way.
But it worked out.
Starve a cold by setting
Governor Richardson into fever.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: The
other conversation
I'd had with him,
we wanted to engage
in the negotiations
on Shalit, but we
had to get Suleiman's approval.
And I remember talking
on the phone with him
before I'd met him, and he
said, yes in the conversation.
But then he started
talking again.
And I hung up.
Now, did you guys see
"Moneyball," the movie?
All right.
Remember when Brad Pitt
is negotiating and trading
for new ball players and Jonah
Hill, his assistant, says,
hey, the general manager
still was on the phone.
You cut him off.
And Brad Pitt said, when you get
the answer you want, hang up.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Let's spend a
few minutes talking about North
Korea, then we'll go to
everybody's questions.
So I'm extraordinarily
thankful to the governor
for one of the great trips of
my lifetime with my daughter
to North Korea.
And this started when we met
in New York, Jared Cohen, who
of course, had set this
up along with a couple
of our other friends.
And I couldn't quite figure out
what the governor was up to,
but we became good friends when
the State Department found out
we were going and told
us we couldn't go.
So I called up the
governor, and he
said, oh, they say
that all the time.
Is that roughly correct?
KEVIN BLEYER: Yes,
but not to me.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: No.
It's true.
The State Department, and we
have a good diplomatic corps,
and I'm not criticizing them,
but they're very cautious.
They don't want anyone
else in our foreign policy,
anybody else except,
quote the professionals.
And I happened to think
that with North Korea,
we need a new policy.
We need to have a dialogue,
not necessarily a negotiation,
but a dialogue that
leads to negotiation.
Isolating them,
punishing them, that's
not the way I
personally think you
deal with other countries that
have nuclear weapons, that
have missiles, that
are unfriendly.
And so they said, well, Eric
and governors and Kevin's trip
are not timely.
The State Department said that.
But I felt that we made a
difference in that trip.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So
right before we leave,
I get a phone call from
Denis McDonough who is now
the Chief of Staff, who says,
we don't want you to go.
And I said, why?
He said, the timing is wrong.
And I said, well, why?
Well, what's going
to happen is there's
going to be an escalation.
We're going to retaliate.
They're going to do this.
They're going to do something
else, we're going to retaliate.
And I said, well, we're going
to be back on Wednesday.
Could you retaliate
after Wednesday?
And he laughed.
And it was pretty
clear in talking
to Jared and to the governor
that we would be OK.
So we showed up and for those
of you who haven't seen it,
my daughter wrote
a blog which has
been read by many,
many people now,
which is just sort of a
26-year-old summary of what
it's like to show up in the
world's last repressive state.
What I remember the
most about North Korea,
aside from the bizarreness
of it, is the temperature.
And the governor in the book
talks a lot about the fact
that we were heavily
photographed with exactly,
you never changed your scarf.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Right.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And
it was so cold,
we had to wear all of
our outfits inside.
And I did not understand how
disabling extreme cold is.
And this is a country
with no energy,
and I developed a
tremendous sense of sadness
for Kenneth Bae who
is the gentleman, one
of the goals we had was trying
to get him out of the gulag.
Because I'm sure
he was literally
sitting there shivering and what
shiver is, shivering to death.
That's how disabling this was.
And I also remember the
governor, because he would
always sort of
layout the framework,
and I would sort of
assist, is repetition,
repetition, repetition.
Trying and trying and trying.
Take us through
what you were trying
to do with us as
leading our team.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON:
Well, on that trip,
I was trying to do
three things, one
was Kenneth Bae, the
American, detained unfairly,
Korean American in a gulag.
And we tried to do that, get
him out or at least get him
medical treatment.
His trial hadn't started, so
we were pushing for his trial.
And after his trial, usually
negotiations can move forward.
The second was saying
to the North Koreans
a new leader had come in,
Kim Jong-un, 30 years old.
Nobody knew anything
about him, but they'd
increased the escalation.
They'd increase
missile launchers.
They detonated a nuclear
weapon underground.
And I'm saying to them,
what are you doing?
You're driving everybody away.
You want food,
fuel, sanctions off.
This is not the way to do it.
Why are you doing this?
I know you.
Take my advice.
Just cool down.
Needless to say, the
uncertainty of the leadership
there, and we tried to see,
Eric and I and Kevin, the dear
leader.
He wouldn't see us,
but later he saw
Dennis Rodman,
which ticked me off.
And then the last
objective, and I
think Eric has being
very, very self effacing,
and this is the Google message,
which I say everywhere,
the technology, the
American technology.
We went into this
university, and Eric
will tell a little
bit about that--
KEVIN BLEYER: Kim Il-sung
University, the E-Library.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Kim
Il-sung University.
They had all these people
on their computers,
but they were
software engineers,
professionals there,
professors there.
Eric came in with his Google
stuff, and he was the star.
They were fascinated.
The political
leadership, and Eric
was spreading the importance
of the internet, how
if you've read his book,
that's the essence of his book,
"The Digital Age."
But I really felt if
they were exposed,
the North Korean leadership,
to just expanding
the internet to not just
the elite that have it,
very small group, but to
universities, the software
engineers, this would
be good not just
for the people in
North Korea, but it
might lead to an
Arab Spring there,
an opening that doesn't exist.
But I was just
another politician.
They all went over
to talk to him.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I was the
rock star of the group.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: And I was
stuck with Kevin in the corner.
But give them your impression.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yeah.
Well, I agree with
all that, and you
go through this
in the book some.
Let's talk a little bit
about North Korea today.
So after our visit, they did
actually open up a few things.
They allowed, for example, 3G
roaming on their million or so
phones that are, in fact, used.
There's a partnership with
a company called Orascom.
It's an Egyptian company
which actually provides this,
and they actually opened up.
Shortly thereafter,
they turned it back off.
They decided to do this
further escalation of conflict
with South Korea.
For some bizarre reason,
they close the factories
that are on the
border that provide
foreign currency for
the Northern country.
They spent three months
screaming at each other.
The new South Korean
prime minister
was a new leader, says
she's going to retaliate.
Everything gets worse.
And now in the last few
weeks, it's gotten better.
I'm going to be in South
Korea in a couple of weeks
where I'm going to
meet with these people
again and try to figure out
the South Korean view of all
of this.
So I can't tell whether North
Korea is better or worse, more
liberal, more conservative,
or just crazier.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: You
know, my assessment, Eric,
is, I don't know the answer,
and I've been there probably
as many times as any American.
The uncertainty is
because of this new leader
who has assumed power.
He's consolidated
his military power.
His name is Kim Jong-un.
He's 30 years old.
He was educated in Switzerland.
His father had the choice of
three of his sons leading,
and they picked the youngest
because the other two had
problems, were
playboys, et cetera.
But this guy, nobody
knows what makes him tick.
What I suspect is happening is,
he is being manipulated right
now by, unfortunately,
the harder line
members of the
Korean people's army,
the military,
which is enormously
powerful with the people in the
party in the Communist Party
in North Korea, that are
anti engagement, anti US.
My hope is that this
is just a phase where
with all this bluster
that he throws,
all these missile
launchers, he's
establishing and
consolidating his own power
within the country,
not that he's
going to have difficulty
in an election
because it's a cult
of personality.
My only point there,
Eric, is I think whatever
you could do to get the
South Koreans to engage more
with the North Koreans when it
comes to family reunification.
The Kaesong facility is a high
tech facility that employees
about 50,000 North
Koreans, I don't
know how many thousand South
Koreans, keep that going.
Any kind of economic engagement,
family reunification.
And then maybe there's
a big unknown element.
The Chinese have influence
over North Korea,
and I think they're
starting to get ticked off
with all the bellicosity
of the North Koreans.
And if they put real
pressure on North Korea,
because they provide
food and fuel,
I think you may see
a more moderate.
ERIC SCHMIDT: One of
the things that we
learned was that North Korea is
completely dependent on China
for water, power, and energy.
So if China were to decide that
they didn't like what the dear
leader is doing, they
could stop it in a second.
KEVIN BLEYER: There are a
few famous stories of Chinese
giving aid to North Korea,
true or not, we're not sure,
but they would often
send this aid via trains
and the North Koreans would say,
thanks for the aid, and thanks
for the trains.
They would keep them as
well, and the engineers
would have to find
a way to get back
sometimes walking
across the border.
It's true.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Let's go
to a few Dory questions,
and maybe we could get a couple
people here in the audience
as well.
There's a series
of questions that
have been previously
submitted, Governor,
and I'll just read them, and
then maybe you can answer them.
And they're all sort
of in a similar vein.
How do you negotiate
when one party is not
interested in any compromise?
In "The Charisma Myth."
Olivia Fox explains the
professional negotiators
could accurately predict
the outcome of negotiations
fairly early using
one simple clue.
Whoever has the less
endurance for silence loses.
How do you negotiate when one
party is holding hostages?
What are your top
three negotiating tips
for daily life?
What do you do in
extreme situations
when the other party is
just unwilling to negotiate?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Well, I
mean, there are cases here
where, my view is you can make
a deal with almost anyone.
That's a fundamental premise.
KEVIN BLEYER: Which is why he
got the nickname undersecretary
for thugs.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Right.
And I believe the
most important element
there is, you have to relate
to that person personally,
and you have to
do it real quick.
But to do that, you have
to do a little research.
You just can't go
in and tell a joke.
I want to know who
the last person that
talked to this dictator.
I want to-- if I still have
access to intelligence files.
What makes this person tick?
Where is he vulnerable?
Why is he meeting with me?
There must be a reason if
he's taking the meeting.
Then what I think
is essential is
you have to break
through the glass
and let the other
side know with candor,
what is the other side getting
out of the negotiation?
In some cases, it's very little.
There's one case that
I use another joke,
but also somebody
that was refusing
to let this American
journalist out.
His name was Salopek from
the "Chicago Tribune."
Bash-- what's his name, Kevin?
KEVIN BLEYER: You got it right.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: In Sudan.
KEVIN BLEYER: Yeah.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON:
Well, what's his name?
KEVIN BLEYER: Bashir.
You just said it.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Bashir.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Bashir.
KEVIN BLEYER: The
convicted ICC war criminal.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: In all the
lists, the worst dictator
in the world, it's
always Bashir of Sudan.
Well, he likes me.
Anyway, I'd gotten
three Red Cross workers
12 years before from
Sudan, not Americans.
And I thanked Bashir 13 years
ago for turning them over.
He didn't have to do it.
This is another negotiation
that's in the book.
But with Salopek, it was a case
where nobody could get him out,
even Barack Obama as a
senator had traveled there,
and he couldn't get them out.
He couldn't even
meet with Bashir.
US government couldn't do it.
So it was intractable.
And this guy was mad, Bashir
was mad at the journalist
because the
journalist had written
that Bashir was terrible
and the Darfur case.
And so Bashir had imprisoned
Salopek and these two
black Chadians that carried the
equipment for the journalists.
They were in jail
in southern Sudan.
So I went to Bashir.
The family came to
see me, and I don't
get involved in prisoner issues
unless the family asked me.
Then after a letter,
then we get involved.
We try to be helpful.
We don't charge anything.
We do the diplomacy.
And so I went to see this man,
Bashir, and we were desperate.
We didn't know what
it was going to take.
Salopek was sick, so I took
his wife, Salopek's wife,
and I said to his wife, we're
going to meet with Bashir.
And I want you to do one
thing in the meeting.
I want you to cry,
and show some emotion,
and you know, that you want
to get your husband out.
I said, you do want
to get him out, right?
So we had the
meeting, and I kept
pleading with Bashir, and this
woman, bright, smart woman,
she wouldn't cry.
And I'd look at her.
She finally did.
KEVIN BLEYER: You
started peeling onions.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Very
effectively, she did.
And so I say to Bashir, come on.
Are you going to give
me Salopek or not?
He said, OK.
You got him.
But the two Chadians,
"they're enemies of the state.
I'm not going to let them go!"
I said, Bashir, I can't
leave with just one person.
I got to get them all.
And you know, we went
back and forth, back,
and I said I'm going
to try this one.
I said, OK, Bashir.
You're a politician.
I'm a politician.
How's it going to
look, and he nods.
His last election he got 98%,
you know, like some election,
right?
I said, Bashir, how can I go
back to the United States,
and you know I have
political ambitions.
And he almost said, well,
I'm ready to endorse you.
I said no.
He actually said something
to the AP reporter
that was with us.
That wasn't helpful.
Anyway, I said to
him, come on, Bashir.
How can I leave with a
white guy going with me
and the two black
guys staying behind?
It was like, I've gotten
grief for saying this,
but I did say it.
And he looked at me and like
Castro he burst out laughing.
He'd laughed and
laughed and laughed.
And he called in his staff,
and he told them the joke.
And he said, OK.
Go.
ERIC SCHMIDT: At
which point, you
headed right to the airport.
KEVIN BLEYER: Well,
actually, with a crying wife.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yeah.
And you got them all.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON:
We got them all.
ERIC SCHMIDT: That's great.
We had a question here.
Somebody had a
question that stood up?
There's a microphone.
Use the mic here.
AUDIENCE: When do
you stop negotiation?
Meaning, is there any point
you reach where you say,
I can't do anymore?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: You've
got to keep going.
You've got to be patient.
I believe in a negotiation where
the next concession you want
is for them to meet again.
Keep going after it.
With North Korea, when I got
a couple of American pilots
that had been down, this
was one of my first,
I told the North
Koreans, I am not
leaving North Korea
until I get the pilots.
One of them was dead that
had been down and helicopter
pilots off the DMZ.
You just keep going,
you're respectful,
but you don't take no.
But then you avoid
mistakes like I
made in Cuba of getting too hot.
ERIC SCHMIDT: You're obviously
a pretty fearless guy.
Have you ever actually
been scared for your life?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Yeah.
I was scared with
Saddam Hussein.
I was scared on that
first North Korean trip.
One time in the Sudan, in the
Bush, there was rebel groups.
They held three Americans.
They had all these
kids with AK-47s,
these little African
kids 11 years old,
and we had no security.
Yeah.
Sure you do.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Next question.
AUDIENCE: Governor
Richardson, what
is your advice for
Americans and other citizens
of the Western world who want
to go and travel to the DPRK
and see it as you have?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Well,
the first thing you do
is let the American
Embassy know.
Secondly,--
ERIC SCHMIDT: Don't be
a Christian missionary?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Yeah.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Don't try to--
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Be very clear.
Don't take any
technology with you
because it gives them an op--
don't take your Google stuff.
Because that gives
them an excuse.
Third, go commercially, go
openly, like Eric and I did.
We went through Beijing.
That's the only
place you can fly to.
Be careful.
It's a Russian plane, you know.
KEVIN BLEYER:
Actually, Air Koryo
is the airline that we took.
It's the North Korean Airlines.
And it's never crashed.
But I mean, it's
officially never crashed.
It's actually the second
most dangerous airline,
they just don't report it.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So we're clear.
Air Koryo has the lowest
customer satisfaction
in the entire world.
KEVIN BLEYER: And
beyond that, yeah.
Right?
I don't need technology to
show you one quick anecdote.
We had given up our technology.
We knew it was in safe hands in
the Beijing office of Google,
because after all China is the
safest place to some material.
But we arrived there,
and we had given away
most of our technology,
our phones, everything.
So when we got to the
foreign ministry guest house,
I think we had arranged,
all right, we're
going to meet is 730 in
the lobby the next morning.
And as we're walking to
our rooms, a couple of us
said, wait a minute,
I don't have my phone.
I can't tell the time.
So how are we going to
know when to get up?
And we'd been told
that everyone--
ERIC SCHMIDT: It's called a
wake up call at the hotel.
KEVIN BLEYER:
Well, I don't think
that was an option
the first night
because we hadn't arranged it.
We didn't know how to do it.
So we actually just said, well,
we know the rooms are bugged,
so just go in and say, I'd like
to wake up at 7:30, please.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So Jared
announced that he was concerned
about cameras in his
room, so he would
shower in his bathing suit.
And I actually slept, and
this is true, with the door
open because I figured they
knew everything anyway.
KEVIN BLEYER: Why not?
The vent in the shower,
the vent in the shower,
was made by Panasonic.
ERIC SCHMIDT: OK.
Next question.
KEVIN BLEYER: Suspicious.
AUDIENCE: Governor
Richardson, you used the word,
this guy's a bad guy.
He's a bad guy.
Is that any way to start
a negotiation particularly
when who is good and who is
bad is a very fungible concept?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON:
Well, I was referring
to President Clinton
did actually say that.
The bad guys like me.
And what I do in the book,
actually, it was my publisher.
I didn't think of it.
He calls them a shark.
Shark is a more
generous attribute
than calling somebody a bad guy.
But yeah, you've
got to be careful.
You can insult people.
I mentioned that
Cuba instance, when
I said the Cubans
were unreasonable.
Try to not get personal
except to connect
with the other person.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And
an interesting thing
in the bizarre
negotiation in DC, things
became so bad between
the people that one
of the political leaders
had his staff release
the emails from the other side
onto the blogosphere, right?
in order to embarrass
them in between meetings.
I mean, it was brutal.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Hi,
Governor Richardson.
So have you ever like
been in such a situation
that when you're trying to
make a personal connection
with a dictator you're trying to
be humorous and telling a joke
but the other one just
didn't get, and feel
like you're too personal.
Have you met the situation,
and how you would deal with it?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Well, you
know, the North Koreans,
they don't think like we do.
We believe the
concept of negotiation
is the quid pro quo.
You do something.
I do something.
The North Koreans
don't believe in that.
They believe that their
position is the right one.
And the concession they make
is, they'll give you a few weeks
to come to their position.
That they're concession.
And when you have that
mindset against you,
remember this is a
cult of personality,
you've got to be careful
sometimes about the humor.
You know, with North
Korea, Eric, these guys,
we try to be as
serious as we can.
We want to drive home a message.
You want to be candid,
but at the same time,
so I won't say you delete the
humor from the North Koreans,
but you're selective
in how you use it.
KEVIN BLEYER: They
weren't totally humorless.
One of the last
nights we were there,
there was a moment when I
think maybe Jared had said
to the woman who they called
the Condi Rice of North Korea,
Kevin actually has been a
writer for "The Daily Show."
Her eyes lit up.
She said, Jon Stewart?
Next time you come you
have to bring him with you.
I thought two thoughts.
One, next time I come,
is that an invitation,
and the second
thought is, I don't
think Jon Stewart would
come to North Korea.
ERIC SCHMIDT: OK.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: I was just taking
a few pages on your chapter
on Venezuelan, your interactions
with Hugo Chavez including
one of the first defining
moments of the US
and Venezuelan
relationship, which
was his first visit
to the White House.
But aside from your
experience with the bad guy,
can you elaborate more on
mistakes done by other US
officials along those 14 years
of really bad relationship?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Well,
my view with Hugo Chavez
is encapsulated in the thought
that our policy towards him
was basically ignore him.
This was US policy.
It was almost stated.
I think that was a
mistake, Clinton, Bush.
And you're right.
I went to his inaugural when
he was first made president.
He was insulted that I went and
not President Clinton or Gore.
So that was like his first--
I won't say that was decisive.
So I think ignoring
somebody doesn't make sense.
I think eventually
you have to engage.
I always feel that
Latin America is
a part of the world we
should pay more attention to.
But right now, you know our
relations with Venezuela
is not good.
Our relations with
Nicaragua is not good,
with Cuba, it's not good,
with Bolivia, it's not good.
We barely have
ambassadors there.
With Ecuador, it's not good.
So ignoring is a
policy option, but I
would prefer engaging, engaging
in technology interactions,
and academic interactions.
And once in awhile have the
Secretary of State visit
even if there are differences.
I think that only
inflames a country more.
With Venezuela, I
was at the election
of the new president, Maduro.
I don't know if he really
won. it was so close.
But he reached out to me
knowing that I was an America
and I was an observer of the
organization of Americans.
And he sent a message,
well, I'd like
to improve the
relationship with the US.
And this guy, Maduro,
he's not like Chavez was.
Chavez was very strong.
His people believed in him.
And the problem with
Maduro, a few days
after, he says to the
world, I'll take Snowden.
He's in Russia.
I'll let him come in.
By the way, this
may not be popular.
I'm not a big fan of
Snowden, what he did.
I mean, that's the National
Security of the United States.
For him to decide he's going
to release what's right
and what's wrong, I
think that's wrong.
But did I answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Thank you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: OK.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Governor Richardson,
I'd like to hear from you.
What kind of
negotiation you think
might help to convince
the Chinese leaders,
those new leaders to open up the
so-called great firewall given,
you know, they
have only a quarter
of the internet
is running there.
ERIC SCHMIDT: You remember
from our discussions
that the Chinese have a
censorship portal, which
was known colloquially as
the great firewall that
sits between Google and
the Chinese citizens
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON:
Yeah, but, Eric,
guys fixed that problem,
didn't you or not?
Didn't we not?
I know you're pushing
it, but wasn't there
some progress on that or not?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I think
it's on negotiation,
and we're losing it.
KEVIN BLEYER: Perhaps
they need a mediator.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: You know,
look, we should not fear China.
You know, American politics,
oh, every campaign, the Chinese,
bah, bah, bah.
First, we should think of China
as a strategic competitor.
We should also think of
China as a country that
is trying to decide
where it wants to go.
When I was at the UN, they
were already a major power.
They only paid 3% of the budget.
We paid 28% of the UN.
And they'd say, well,
we're a developing country.
We can't afford more than 3%.
Now, they're paying more
now, but they still, I
don't think they've
decided in terms
of their great
economic power what
they're going to do with it.
That's my theory.
I may be wrong.
My point is that the
American-Chinese relationship
has a lot of different handles.
There's the North Korea side,
the national security side,
military presence in East
Asia, the technology side,
the trade side they control.
They spoke out on the shut down.
They were worried about
their investments in the US.
So we have to be very
careful in this relationship
and know that it has
a lot of branches.
And when you start
insulting each other,
the Chinese are very
big on saving face,
on decorum, on proper channels.
I wouldn't use too
much humor with them
if I were negotiating with them.
But I think on the technology
side, one of the things
that the Chinese will say at
the end of the conference,
I know Eric goes
to a lot of them
like I do as does Kevin, is
the Chinese will blast us
at the conference,
Davos, anywhere.
But then at the end
of the conference,
this is what they say.
They say, OK.
America, clean up your
act, but lead, lead.
What I'm trying to
say is that I think
we just continue
these discussions.
I think the negotiation on
cyber security between the two
countries are
enormously important.
And it's better to try to
make agreements with them
while their policies
are evolving,
and I think they're trying to
decide where they want to go.
Eric, what's your
thought on that?
ERIC SCHMIDT: I
actually agree with you.
Let's have these be the
two final questions,
and then we'll have
a wrap-up question,
and then we'll be done.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Hello,
Governor Richardson.
I wanted to go back to what you
mentioned with regards to Cuba
and American policy.
And you said you were
against the current policy.
I used to have a young
colleague, an American
of Cuban descent, who used
to say that his father was
against changing these policies.
His grandfather was against
changing these policies
and that Americans of Cuban
descent had these opinions
and that they represented
a strong voting block,
and that was one
of the reasons why
things weren't changing
and wouldn't change
until these people
had passed on.
How do you feel about
that assessment?
Is that accurate?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: That
assessment is accurate
because on a presidential race,
Florida and New Jersey are key.
Florida, the Cuban American
vote is very strong.
The same in New Jersey where
Senator Menendez is from.
Where's Menendez-- what
town in New Jersey?
KEVIN BLEYER: I don't recall.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: One
of you guys, come on.
One of you guys are from
New Jersey, aren't you?
Eric, what's that town
right after New York City?
ERIC SCHMIDT: We are Google.
We could look this up.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Yeah.
By the way, Eric had said you
guys did a Google map on North
Korea, and I got a message Eric
wanted to do it before we left.
I said, Eric, let's wait
till after we get back.
And it was a great map.
But my point is that the Cuban
American vote is changing.
The younger
generation is saying,
we've had this hostile policy
towards Cuba, the embargo.
Castro is still in power.
The country is not doing well.
What are we getting
out of the embargo?
So there's questioning going on.
And I think Obama has moved
in the right direction on side
issues, like more
family visits, loosening
the opportunity of travel
of Americans going to Cuba.
It's easier to get in right now.
But this Alan Gross case, which
I mentioned, is a big barrier
and the Cuban five, five
Cubans in American jails
that have been in
jail for spying,
are the human barriers
between the two countries.
But that vote this
changing a bit.
Obama won Florida and
just about the only thing
I'll say about
the Hispanic vote,
on this shutdown and
the immigration reform,
the Republican
Party only got 29%
of the Hispanic vote, the
lowest they've ever had.
And if they don't change
that policy on immigration,
they're going to become
a minority party.
And right now the Tea Party
Republicans in the house
are adamantly opposed to any
changes in the immigration law,
and that's going to hurt
them with Cuban Americans,
with Mexican Americans,
Central Americans that
are part of this American
political fabric.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Thank you.
And our final question.
AUDIENCE: Governor
Richardson, I would just
like to ask you on a comment
on the situation in Syria,
how the ongoing
negotiations don't
seem to bring much in
the whole situation
with attack and not attacking.
What's your view on this?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON:
Well, God, I love,
besides my love for
Google, I love Facebook.
I love to read all the comments
on Twitter on this issue.
I came out saying I support
Obama in the military strikes.
Why?
Because I think there has
to be a consequence of cost
when there's a violation
of human rights of chemical
weapons used.
I think it's an
international crime.
Now, I'm not for
intervening with boots
on the ground and
more than that.
So I thought that
was a right response.
Now, what has happened since?
Right now, everybody
dumps on the UN.
But you know who's enforcing
the chemical weapons ban, which
I think is going
to happen in Syria?
The UN.
Who won the Nobel Prize?
The chemical weapons
investigators.
They won the Nobel.
I think that Pakistani
woman should have won it.
But apart from that--
KEVIN BLEYER: Malala.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON:
The little girl.
What's her name?
KEVIN BLEYER: Malala.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Yeah.
I mean, jeez.
This little girl was
such a great symbol.
So what I think is going
to happen in Syria,
I think Russia, and I'm
being generous here,
I think Russia realizes
that Assad is a loser.
He's going to go down.
He's not popular.
His own military, I believe,
is going to take him down.
Now, a lot of people
disagree with me.
They say, oh, you know,
nothing is going to change.
Obama made a mistake.
I think we were actually
lucky that what happened
was an opportunity that the
Russians presented saying, OK.
What if we get rid of
all the chemical weapons?
Will this deter the
military strike?
And of that negotiation
leads to a negotiation
on the future of Assad on
a political transition,
I think it's a major
accomplishment.
But the situation is unstable.
There's no question about it.
But I think the Russians know
that this guy Assad is a loser.
So if they are maneuvering to
have a political transition
after the chemical
weapons are banned,
and I believe the
inspectors will make sure
that does happen.
You know, everybody's a cynic.
Oh, it's not going to happen.
I'm an optimist by nature.
Do you disagree?
AUDIENCE: No.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: No?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Kevin?
He's negotiating.
KEVIN BLEYER: Yeah.
Right.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Kevin.
after the successful book tour,
what are you going to do next?
KEVIN BLEYER: That's
a good question.
I don't know how to
live this down or up
or what have you after traveling
the world with the two of you
and also feeling
like I've traveled
the world for the last three
decades and sitting at his knee
and learning all the
negotiations he's
had with these amazing people.
I feel like I've
lived there too.
I was in those rooms and
hopefully, the book as well
gives you a sense of that.
So quite frankly, I'm
a little bit exhausted.
I'll be honest with you.
Next I feel like there's---
I'm told that political satire
to some degree, the fake news
world is the growth industry--
ERIC SCHMIDT: They have
generated so much new material
for you.
KEVIN BLEYER: So
apparently, yeah.
I'm going to keep pursuing
that and see what happens.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Governor,
after this is over,
you have a foundation
you've been heavily engaged,
I know, in Cuban issues.
What do you think your
next negotiation is?
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Right
now, I believe, by the way,
I formed a foundation
with Robert Redford.
I am passionate about protecting
wild horses and mustangs.
And there's a move afoot
to start slaughtering them
because they're proliferating.
There's no question about it.
I just negotiated an agreement
with the Navajo nation,
which had announced
a policy of killing
these horses because they
were overrunning the Navajo
reservation.
So in exchange for them not
doing this, the Navajos,
we're providing what is
called PCP, birth control,
sanctuaries for the horses.
So I have this other foundation,
the international foundation.
We specialize in trying to
get political prisoners out.
We specialize in relations
with difficult countries,
like North Korea, training
the legislature where
Eric Schmidt's daughter
helped us train
the legislature in
Burma on technology.
But apart from that,
Eric, right now,
I've been 32 years in the
public sector in government.
I do speeches.
I've got a speaker's bureau.
I serve on boards.
I have a relationship with
this PR firm called APCO.
But I stay involved
in the policy.
I'm a defender of the president.
I think he's done
a good job on TV.
And my last point is, I'm
making a little money.
OK?
And Eric, my taxes are too high.
What do we do about it?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Kevin.
KEVIN BLEYER: There's
one, I would be remiss.
Forgive me.
I would not let this opportunity
go by in this particular day.
As I stare across
Governor Richardson
and see you across
the way to not
tell this very quick anecdote.
That this is the only place
I would be able to tell it
nor should I tell,
but I will do it.
As you may recall, we didn't
get to see Kim Jong-un.
But on the day we
thought we might,
we were instead brought
to the Palace of the Sun.
Palace of the Sun
is the mausoleum
where King Jong-il and
Kim Il-sung are actually
laid out in state, embalmed.
They get the Madame
Tussauds treatment.
I didn't know that.
So I'll jump to
the chase and say
after seeing the
entire mausoleum,
you get brought into the actual
moment where Kim Jong-il is
laying there,
bathed in red light.
You're surrounded
by military police.
We happened to be there on a day
when only military police were
also allowed to visit, so
we kind of got separated.
We ended up being with
our own essentially troops
and military police going in.
You're supposed bow at
the side, bow at the feet,
walk around the head and
bow at the other side.
We didn't bow, but
the military did.
And as they bowed, I was staring
across Jim Jong-il's nose,
and Eric Schmidt is on
the other side of it.
And he kind of looks to
the side, stares at me,
and at the absurdity
of the situation,
I got the worst fifth
grade giggle fit.
I just close my eyes and
just every muscle tensed,
and thought I cannot
start laughing now.
There are military please.
There are 50 military
police around here,
and I'm pretty sure I would
have been this escorted away.
But I just thought as I was
staring across your nose--
ERIC SCHMIDT: And this
is their most sacred site
in North Korea.
KEVIN BLEYER: Absolutely.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I
hope in our hour,
you got a sense of why we've
become such good friends.
And it's a bit of
advice for all of you.
If you ever find yourself in
a foreign country with five
or six fellow
travelers, turn off
your devices a little while.
Get to know them because
they're going to be fascinating.
We've had such a good time.
Thank you for this.
Thank you for coming, and
thank you all for coming.
GOV.
BILL RICHARDSON: Thank you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Thank you.